[Music]
freedom to political prisoners that's
what these protesters are shouting
people in Moscow are showing their anger
over a recent government crackdown some
carrying posters of those who have been
detained for up to four years for
participating in unsanctioned protests
opposition figure Alexei Navalny who
himself was detained for organizing some
of the protests called for their release
a few people were released but many more
are still in jail why did they release
them is it because they have a
conscience are they ashamed because they
have children no they let them go
because they're afraid their ratings
will drop the three-and-a-half year
sentence against 23 year old actor Pavel
Ustinov has led to a public outcry even
in pro-government circles he was
arrested in late July near a protest he
says he was not even taking a pardon
opposition candidate Yulia gala Mina
spent 35 days in detention after she was
banned from running in the Moscow City
elections that took place early
September the society doesn't want to
tolerate such a rude physical
restriction of freedom against political
opponents even the regime's supporters
want this regime to have an equal and
honest dialogue with its opponents this
is not happening
also the detention of a 21 year old
student has angered many he is facing
extremism charges for a YouTube video
and his detention has been extended
until December by handing out stiff
sentences to people many here consider
our innocent the authorities not only
angered people but also brought them
together from all walks of life it's a
demand for justice that might be hard to
ignore thousands of people including
doctors scientists and priests have
signed letters urging the government to
release the prisoners some of the
pressure seems to have helped Pavel
Ustinov has been put under house arrest
while he's waiting for his appeal to be
heard the outcome of his case will be
closely watched step fasten al Jazeera
Moscow